vous avez dû en voir passer des modèles
je vous ai reçus et qu'est ce qu'elle
vous dise jacky vous avez dû en voir
passer des vedettes tout
non sauf une eddie barclay et qu'est-ce
qu'il dit lui il ne dit pas monsieur
il s'est alors il dit bonsoir bonsoir
assez en forme ça va que va bien tout va
bien tu vois plusieurs en blanc les
vacances la fabrique t dictée dans le
midi tout habillés en blanc quoi ah oui
ça passe mieux à la machine devrait
changer tous les jours tout va bien tu
as quel âge l'a71 maintenant ouais on
verra après talât bourg quand même non
donc tout va tout va une femme charmante
ses amis durables des artistes qui
m'entourent et mon activité et débordant
coin dis moi tu as eu ce cancer quand
même ya un peu plus de dix ans
maintenant
la gorge ça prouve qu'on ne meurt pas
toujours tu y vas de temps en temps il
te regarde
nous regardons le contrôle du bon
sauvage avait encore génial tu avais
encore du temps tous les combien de
berger été contrôlé à le berger est
contrôlé à peu près toutes les heures et
demie c'est à dire tu vois tu vois
combien de deux bergers par jour
douzaine au d'ailleurs je le fais un
berger barclay parce que maintenant
on va lancer ça au mois de septembre moi
je dois boire beaucoup d'eau en plein
jeu bois du berger avec beaucoup d'eau
par jour alors une douzaine une douzaine
de 1 seulement et ça ne tourne pas la
tête mais ça ne change pas les fans les
plus moches pour des faits et si tu en
vois pas qu'est ce qui se passe aux
rumeurs je bois du bordeaux ouais mais
si tu vois pas de berger pas de bordeaux
chez grave je meurs alors il business ça
marche tu fais des affaires toujours
nagé une dizaine de sociétés qui font
des productions particulière alors
allons-y alors il ya d'abord le les
disques il ya délit qui s'appelle
comment les disques barclay libéré dit
barclays barclays mais il ya une société
qui organise des fêtes jeudi qu'ils
organisent des fêtes ça se passe comment
si on veut se faire organiser une fête
par barclays qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
on téléphone à mon téléphone à mon
collaborateur à la marouani on
un peu particulière si c'est pour une
grande fête pour lancer un produit pour
ce pas un grand mariage union de
manifestations quelle qu'elle soit et
puis on y organise par rapport à la
personnalité à lui organise la fête sur
mesure avec des orchestres nationaux
même citizen bien une bd à temps pour
les fêtes
tu garantit les stars ne peut pas il ne
peut jamais garantir les stars mais on
peut en faire venir mais ça coûte
combien une fête organisée par barclays
autres 500 1000 et
on avait quand même les mecs te paye
toujours toujours lama qui dit c'était
pas bien
non non non liza minnelli est pas venu
jeune jolie arrive en retard j'ai jamais
arriver ces chaînes privées tant fait
combien de fait parlant d'un organisme
combien une demi douzaine à combelles a
quand même
et alors et en parfums alors le parfum
on l'a sorti quelques quelques mois
alors j'ai appelé le parfum saint tropez
et le maire de saint tropez monsieur
spada lui n'est pas content lui dit
qu'on n'a pas le droit de prendre le
volant de sa ville pour se l'attribuer à
des fins commerciales
j'ai d'abord s'est passé pas de nom de
sa ville c'est le nom de la ville de sa
ville aujourd'hui les maires de metz
après fut maire de ce que je peux pas
dire que c'est sa ville sa ville comme
si la mienne elle a rien donc ne sont
pas s'attribuer le nom d'une ville
pendant qu'est ce qu'on peut s'offrir
s'attribuer le nom de paris mais ça le
rend par exemple sorti un parfum qui
s'appelle paris des leafs à l'europe
dommage est sorti centrapel du barclays
toute cette bande de saint tropez convoi
dans paris match ou visiter à sellaband
si mabanda - film - c'est la manoeuvre
avec quatre saisons
les gens qui veulent absolument faire
partie de la bande ils sont prêts à
quelle bassesse pour y arriver
une bonne question
quelle bassesse mu 1,8 royalement et
j'envoie des avions d'hélicoptères
quelques fois même des champions à
donner de l'argent
tout ça pour vous avoir chez chez eux
oui ou venir chez nous et le pire que tu
as vu dans le genre c'est quoi wade
jours qui viennent en hélicoptère
ils viennent quelquefois s'imposer comme
ça les sort dans sur le terrain les
travaux d'aider des gens qui attendent
même derrière les grilles de la
le lot de la porte d'entrée qui
force parce que la porte de semaine les
gens voilà on voterait vous gagnez un
tableau tout la nature d'incroyable et
tu fais quoi pour t'en débarrasser
je suis pas là j'ai obtenu comment dans
un casting c'est à dire casting à lyon
ouais qui fait des castings pour trouver
ses fans du castet quoi leur expliquent
nos noms jean castex pour trouver de
nouvelles angélique remarqué de bizarre
ah bon j'en ai discuté avec mon ami
robert hossein et ça va se faire 2
trouver la nouvelle michel mercier et je
trouvais cette dame
tu m'as garder pour toi finalement oui
c'est moi mais ça s'est passé comment au
départ je vous dire comment et à draguer
en gros quoi bon ça je suis allé à ce
casting avec des copines parce qu'en
fait
on allait pourvoir eddie barclay pour
paris et puis dont il m'a dit que
c'était pour jouer au théâtre j'ai dit
que moi en fait jamais fait de théâtre
que c'est pas du tout avoir
et donc je lui par contre j'étais
intéressé par les toucher à la
communication les relations publiques
envisagé de faire d'ailleurs des stages
à la rentrée à paris bon pour résumer la
chose en fait pendant six mois je vous
monte régulièrement à paris
à chaque fois mais pendant six mois j'ai
donc toi tu vas pas céder pendant six
mois et un jour tu as aidé c'est
compliqué ce qu'il a fait pour te faire
céder il s'est fâché une fois donc au
bout pratiquement de six mois ouais il
m'a appelé à lyon tout ce temps là il
était d'une patience vraiment de
galanterie pacifique s'est énervé quoi
ils s'apprêtaient à traiter de quoi de
bernadette soubirous a envie de vivre
avec et alors là la chose s'est fait
très rapidement
ben oui on s'est plus vu pendant quelque
temps puis quand même rappeler celle qui
tarde à fait à ce moment-là journal à
paris ma part à pied elle est arrivée
avec ses valises en hacker croll a dit
non
raccourci raccourci mais celles
habilitées à prouver devant ta porte
cette pratique va bien passer le
week-end et non je savais bien habiter
vrai ou pas un héros là ça fait cinq ans
que vous êtes mariés ça se passe comment
leur faisait un petit bilan
est ce que il est fidèle j'ai tout le
temps semble que le ver est oui non non
non je suis fidèle des fidèles
j'imagine je crois tu crois oui je crois
moi dis moi alors maintenant question
importante est ce que c'est vrai que
valence
non pas du tout déçu j'envoie gens font
certainement dans ma vie ouais ben selon
la jeune torera non non franchement
mesdames bien remplie n'a pas dit avant
que l'épousé tu sais ça va être très dur
avec moi tu n'auras jamais l'enfant et
des rencontres tout ce qu'il m'a dit il
ya quelques temps sur si j'en avais
envie il était d'accord aussi donc là
c'est pour vous en faites pas alors pour
différentes raisons d'abord j'ai deux
enfants d'une part d'autre part j'ai 75
ans où je me demande si vraiment survie
des enfants maintenant sur la suite des
événements ça c'est difficile à vivre
centenaire toi oui
sa nouvelle va d'ivoire norma fin à dix
mois et et huit femmes toi quand même
non c'est le 8ème oui
1 la plus belle ouais était en fête à
divorcer que six fois parce que ta
première femme est décédée au bout d'un
an et demi de mariage
malema est est ce que tu crois que si ça
n'était pas arrivé
est ce que tu crois que tu aurais eu
comme ça tout c'est toutes ces femmes
tout est à ranger dans la vie c'est par
hasard
est ce que tu dis je t'aime ah oui oui
ou très galant il sait y faire avec les
femmes c'est mieux les mecs ans
d'expérience
donc j'aime pas les hommes qui sont trop
sûrs d'eux et ça rien à voir avec
l'expérience
c'est pour ça que je préfère plutôt les
hommes c'est un coup des revenus qui
sont moins sûrs d'eux parce qu'il est
bien c'est bien comment s'y prendre
aussi non ah oui vulin l'expérience dans
tous les domaines - tu vas rester avec
lui s'il reste sympa comme ça oui
[Musique]